americans looking for somewhere new to
live are facing huge challenges whether
they're planning to buy or to rent take
a look at the latest numbers for home
sales they dropped nearly six percent in
july with experts blaming the decline on
a shortage of homes to sell now over the
past year sales are down by about 20
percent and that is forcing more buyers
to continue renting which is pushing up
rental prices as carter evans shows us
some renters are now facing bidding wars
they cannot afford
looking for a place to rent
good luck
michael citron is on the hunt for a
place in los angeles he's a federal
public defender with a legitimate
complaint
i can't even tell you how many places
i've applied for and been rejected from
you're a lawyer you got a good job yeah
and you can't find an apartment yeah
it's and i'm looking with two other
professionals as well
together they tried to rent this
three-bedroom bungalow in south los
angeles for forty one hundred dollars a
month until someone bid the rent up ten
percent
i'd never have expected that there would
be a bidding war
for a 12-month lease across the country
average rents are skyrocketing up 86
percent since last year in redmond
washington 36 in glendale california and
in flugerville texas outside of austin
prices are up triple digits it's leading
to battles for reynolds
when chris baird and his girlfriend
tried to rent this place in denver they
were like you could pay the
30 thousand dollars for the full year up
front
and then we would rent you another
landlord wanted their best offer for
rent
i was like so what we can offer you is
the peace of mind knowing that we're
responsible tenants
uh obviously that didn't go anywhere why
are people bidding so much money over
the asking price uh really just due to
competition post coveted people who are
working remote are now coming back in
high mortgage rates are also pricing out
many would-be home buyers which leads to
more renters according to leasing agent
blake stargle 90 of the situations with
reynolds right now my clients have to
compete he listed a three bedroom in
this l.a building for 4 700 a month i
got 50 inquiries in the first 24 hours
we had offers up to 5 500 on this
property rent on this one bedroom
bungalow was bit up from 1300 to 2000 a
month too much for michael citron whose
current lease is up there's a
possibility that i don't find something
in the next two weeks and then i put my
stuff in storage and stay on a friend's
couch i mean you'd essentially be
homeless yeah which could hurt his
chances of becoming a runner again if
there's a gap in my residency it makes
me less attractive which
again just makes you think if you've
ever experienced homelessness how do you
get out of it for cbs morning's carter
evans los angeles